i weirdly like losing I like going
through the process of trying to win I
think that there should be pain because
my ambition is so great of course I
should have a lot of micro losses
you got your prospective
[Music]
you know you're super motivated full of
optimism do you have down days everybody
has down days and I'm so scared to
answer truthfully which is what I always
do it's surprising how not really I
basically feel that down days are saved
for the death of people you love I
genuinely believe everything else is at
some level a controllable if I was to
lose money if a bad deal happened if a
lot of people you know turned on me or
made fun of me for some reason those
things don't bother me as much the the
death or terminal illness of 20 or 30
people that matter to me the most that
scares me
that's when I'll have a down day if you
come back here and we're hanging out in
six years I would say yes today knock on
wood somebody died right yeah not
getting the deal that I wanted I'm
always optimistic and positive about me
I don't judge myself the way I think
most people do I don't beat myself up
when I have a bad hour day week or month
and that's why I think most people do
when something that really affects you
like during your day so you've got
really a lot of time into your invested
time energy money into and it's not
going right that that to me is part of
the game of trying to be successful you
can't control everything I mean I've
been so right about so many things and
every day I'm in meetings telling people
what's about to happen I don't believe
me and I'm like 20 plus years of a
ridiculous track record like a real one
now and still especially because I talk
about things that are not obviously at
work but like are here but people think
are coming so you kind of like minimize
it in
two things you're already thinking like
long-term bigger person yes picture
automatically that's really funny the
way you said it it just triggered
something in me when something bad
happens my immediate reaction and I mean
bad like something that I think it would
put somebody in a one day to one week
like a real run I immediately go to well
I'm alive and so are the 10 people I
care about
like literally that baby yes he'll like
you know how old people like to help and
like like health is like you know yeah I
mean I actually live it health is wealth
I actually live in plus I I we don't
like losing
I like going through the process of
trying to win I do like a little thing I
do it it struggle because because I
think it's appropriate for my ambition
like I think that there should be pain
because my ambition is so great of
course I should have a lot of micro
losses champions lose rounds they
sometimes even lose fights
Mohammed Ali lost five times but he's an
all-time legend or sexual you know yeah
what was great for me was because I was
an entrepreneur I tested it from the
beginning I was I was learning at five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
there was some I was 22 I was a veteran
in my craft I wasn't just starting most
people are in school and just start at
22 I was an old player in my game at 22
I've been selling and building
businesses my whole life for real like I
know people know my narratives at least
the ones that are watching that know I
don't think I actually really know like
I really did business every minute
always my whole life it's what a passion
about it's what I loved in the summer I
chose to wash people's carves for money
I chose and then you impact like looking
at Jason who I loved so much like my
decision to start a company changed the
course of his life impact is fun for me
impacts fund so I do so much content
like one little Instagram video right
it's like the thought that like I put
made something that got into your head
that brought value that made you want to
meet me that's cool that's cool how life
works
[Music]